uh p adjusted value less than point zero
five i think then you can get all
important pathways yeah
okay
okay so now i would uh
uh ask uh elia and dr grinder to give um
comments on your presentation or any
suggestion that they have
yeah thank you i think overall it's
clear that you've done a lot of work and
now the task ahead is to integrate all
these analysis results and kind of make
sense of what are the clear findings
i think because of the time constraints
this is an exciting update to the
project that you've been working on for
a while and you're obviously addressing
a lot of the issues that came up during
the initial analysis
let's move on to hear a little bit from
dr raghav who is another mentor and then
he can transition to his part of the
presentation so thank you urjah
thank you thank you elia uh i think i'm
audible so that that was a very uh that
was a very detailed and very good work
uh
and i'll be interested to see uh okay
if he's not there yes okay great so i'll
be i'm very much interested to see the
pathway associated with it and then you
can uh do uh
two selected and selected analysis on
the pathway that are shared or that are
not shared completely different between
the normal
stem cells and the glu glioma stem cells
so those are very interesting ones
maybe maybe even more stringent
p value could give you a
reduced set of genes
because you still have a lot of genes to
analyze and and that would
yeah so you can maybe maybe you can
reduce your analysis or downstream
analysis to top
20 or top 15
up regulated genes in top 20 down
regulated genes for each set and then
try to see
if
these top 20 genes are from multiple
pathways or the pathways associated with
these top two digits that should
narrow it down and make your analysis
even more workable because
i mean at the moment you have really a
lot of data to
comprehend with so
right now we i would start with that and
then
and see where it goes and and maybe
extend it to uh
top 50 if if that is that makes even
more meaningful
even more meaning and and
we will see
okay so uh
thank you cheers
so i think that will
that will translate or transition to my
uh talk or presentation
uh i will share my screen right
away i just need to find it well okay
okay
excellent
okay
okay great can everybody see my screen
i think you can yeah yes so we can thank
you so yeah thank you
i am raghavendran bioinformatics mentor
and research consultant with omix logic
let me brief you about my
uh my background and research interests
so i grew up to be a tinkerer kid who is
interested in solving many problems so
right in my younger ages computers and
programming with computers introduced me
to very new puzzles and challenges for
attempting to solve these puzzles and
these challenges were the first step
that took me towards solving puzzles and
asking questions
so during my undergrad education i read
about the potential and the announcement
of the human genome project
that um yeah and then that was the first
research article that i read i didn't
understand it most of it but it it
inspired me uh to a great deal and i
pursued my master's in biophysics so my
natural inclination towards computers
and structural biology bioinformatics
led me to specialization in
computational biology and bioinformatics
so uh after my master's in
bioinformatics or biology biophysics
i joined phd in max plant institute
for biophysical chemistry uh with the
specialization in computational biology
so uh during this tenure i developed
software and designed a lot of
methodologies and pipelines for protein
structural and dynamic studies so my
system of interest during this during
the phd period was proteins associated
with neurodegenerative diseases
so uh when
at the time when the next gen sequencing
technologies uh were starting to get
established in india i came back to
india as a postdoc to the institute of
bioinformatics and applied biotechnology
in bangalore
the potential of the nitrogen sequencing
technique and its application to
multi-omics data analysis these two
combined and piqued my interest in
cancer so you all know
cancer is the leading cause of disease
death worldwide so uh i got naturally
inspired and uh
interested to work with cancer biology
so i contacted professor chandra ramadan
jnu and dr pedro ballister in in
collaboration with dr peter balaster in
insulin france
i proposed a study to understand and to
explore tumor responses to different
treatment achieves
so
this was while i was in bengaluru and i
also agreed to help a friend who was in
need of bioinformatics help in
the dino
genome assembly of a variety of neem
plant so it was only during this
collaborative project i came to realize
how little information was available for
plant bioinformatics in the public
depositories while when you take or when
you compare it with availability of
databases and repositories for human or
bacteria
there is hardly anything for the plants
but there is so much potential to
understand uh plant genetics because
through bioinformatics and through
sequencing techniques um
we can understand the underlying biology
of plant genetics because agricultural
crops have been subjected to artificial
selection for ages irrespective of
geographical location and irrespective
of culture
so i i continue to work with the project
and they are writing up the paper and
i'm still associated with the
department to uh for some
troubleshooting in the pipeline that i
developed
so while uh while all this was going on
the project that we proposed was
successfully funded and so i joined jnu
as a postoperative scientist so uh i
will detail more about the data that i
use for projects and and about the
projects in the discussion uh results in
uh in a short but uh i just wanted to
mention right from my phd years i
enjoyed working with undergrad students
and enjoyed working with students so
this experience tremendously inspires me
and i feel privileged to work with some
of the bright young minds
so i hope and i wish every one of you
will enjoy working with me and as much
as i look forward to working with you
so uh for the next two slides or the
next two slides i want to move on to
speak about the data that i use for the
project on precision oncology let's see
if i can get this rolling yes okay great
so
every once in a while in in science that
groundbreaking research gets published
and the data collected for that work
content contains a lot of potential to
answer a wide variety of scientific
questions and queries so this is one
such paper
and this paper is about a tumor cells
that are grafted into mouse models uh to
to study uh tumor responses to different
treatment regimes so what they did was
they extracted the tumor cells from
cancer patients and then they uh
they sequenced it and from the sequence
they uh
profiled at the gene expression levels
and the gene mutation levels and the
copy number variation levels and then
these tumor cells are grafted into
immunosuppressant mouse
so and these mouse were administered
different and
different set of treatment regimes
and and
and the tumors response to these
treatment regimes were studied and such
mouse or such immunosuppressant mouse
which got administered with tumor grafts
are known as patient derived xenografts
so these pdxs in short and they are
administered 60 different treatments and
and their response were recorded
in change in volume and the ability of
the mouse to survive the disease so such
survival data analysis of 1075 pdx mouse
was released along with this data
along with the study
so this study from this analysis
concludes that the mouse models provide
a better alternative compared to the
cell lines which were traditionally used
because cell lines are often affected by
the petri dishes they are grown on and
heterogeneity is one of the biggest
problem in cell line data
so far
and
at the basic genomic level compared to
the cell lines the genes the
the gene expression levels of the pdxs
resemble more to the tran uh to the
cancer patients than the cell lines cell
line data
and
and
pdxs are also consistent for the data
from these pdxs are also consistent with
extensively studied therapies and
this comparison validates their
applicability to understand the
underlying cancer biology so such a
wealthy of data generates a free throw
of research questions as i already post
so one can employ this data to various
analytical pipelines to study treatment
stratification like can the mutations in
genomic data predict tumor resistance or
vice versa can tumor resistance
relate to significant mutations in those
models
are
our combination of drugs more effective
than single drugs or how uh how does
different combinations of drug work well
or does not work well together or can we
find the underlying biology behind this
or we can also do some precision
medicine study like
do targeted therapy exhibit higher
efficacy than general cytotoxic
treatments because
among these 60 treatments somewhere
general cytotoxic treatments which are
toxic to all cells just they kill cancer
cells more than the normal cells and
some are
some specifically target pathways inside
the cancer cells so can we find out
the underlying differences between these
two treatments
and with the help of multi-omics
integration
can the pdx is broadly represent
the integration diversity because that
was one of the biggest conclusion of
this study where they observed
a diversity among the models which carry
the same cancer cells
from different patients so they
they translate into inter patient
diversity so can we quantify this
diversity or more importantly can we
find the commonality among this
diversity so that we can understand or
we can use it for biomarker analysis
so these are different questions and
what it i used to
use this study to
work on so uh
my aim was to use this pdx data to
design and implement machine learning
models to predict tumor responses to
different treatment regimes and why do
we need to do that so the efficacy or
the effectiveness of the cancer drugs is
very strongly patient dependent
that is why we are moving more and more
towards precision oncology and
personalized medicine because on an
average only 25 percentage of the cancer
patients actually respond to cancer
drugs
but unlike unlike your normal
painkillers
you will have 80 percentage of the
patients responding positively to the
painkillers so currently there is a need
to predict which patient will respond
positively to the treatment and if not
there is no need to spend time and
energy and to treat the patients with
the treatment so
for this study one obviously cannot use
patient data
because of
because of the difficulty the uniformity
among the patient data but we can
actually use
these most model data to predict the
treatment response so how did i do that
the gene expression data the copy number
variation data and the gene mutation
data were the features from which the
machine learning models defines a
function to understand the tumor
response so when this model was
presented a test case it tries to
predict the tumor response to the
particular drug so such a study this
this model was applied to breast cancer
and colorectal cancer pdxs which were
treated for 26 different treatments
so what did we find
traditionally canonically single genes
were used as biomarkers that predict the
onset of cancer and the same set of
single genes were used as a
as a treatment biomarker also
for example if if there is an
association of a gene
to the onset of cancer the same gene was
studied whether this particular cancer
will respond positively or negatively to
any given treatment this is obviously
and
logically is not a very accurate
predictor so that so this this is not a
very successful model but uh
from
from a very uh
from the multi data analysis what we
demonstrate is the
before that i want to uh before that i
want to introduce you to the accuracy
measure that we are measuring the tree
measuring the
machine learning models accuracy levels
so this is matthew's correlation
coefficient where an accuracy of 1 would
mean the perfect accuracy like all the
test data or
perfectly
identified or predicted to be uh how it
responded to the treatment and minus one
would be complete opposite if there is a
positive response the model predicts a
negative
response and around zero would be a
random response so what we want is these
data points to move more more towards
one
so that we get better accuracy of our
machine learning model so uh in that one
so
when the machine learning model was uh
used used to predict on single gene
markers you see the accuracy is not very
great it is actually yeah
it's very bad
so
when multi-gene models were introduced
in place of single gene models the
accuracy is improved and
the accuracy level can further be
improved by
combining or by including more than one
profiles or more than one molecular
profile like
gene mutation data combined with
gene expression data combined with copy
number variation data improves accuracy
tremendously so to quantify we actually
observed we could predict
19 out of 26
treatment regimes
we could predict correctly 19 out of 26
treatment regimes so
this was what we performed and what
could be done what could be done more in
in such a study so one can extend such
an analysis to include patient data from
tcga repository but that involves
extensive curation of the data but one
can still do it
a gene set enrichment analysis like what
oja presented
of the biomarker genes will throw
insight into the biology behind the
response of these tumors to different
treatment levels so uh
this is how we did and
such a study was actually performed for
selected cancer and for selected
treatments so one can obviously extend
the study to all the cancer to find the
commonality of these cancer cells to
react to different treatment regimes
so these are the different future
steps that the team is currently working
on but i finished my part and i joined
promise logic
so i hope this project was informative
and it does inspire you to utilize
curated pdx data this curated pdx data
will be available at the mixed logics
platform shortly and this um
yeah
this platform as you are aware by now
with uh different uh introduction from
elia and from harpreet and from sonalika
provides a very well organized research
fellowship program that i want to speak
about in the next two slides
let me go to the next slide so yes so
from my research experience there are
three main challenges that all
researchers will need to overcome in any
research program and this research
program is designed to target
specifically to address these
one time so a lot of time is actually
spent on learning research methods from
multiple sources with a varying level of
liability but in the end you are going
to use only one or two methods for your
question of interest so what we have the
the learning platform the omics logic
learning platform provides you with a
very well planned learning modules and
course work this course work will
prepare you for any challenges you might
face with the data analysis and or the
biological interpretation of your data
analysis and your research question and
another big challenge in doing
computational work or bioinformatics
work is
is the presence of or is rather there is
a limited access to bioinformatics
expertise or a reduced availability to
bioinformatics experts
for the students so
with
in this program the research fellows
will participate in cutting-edge
bioinformatics research led by mentors
like me
like harpreet and several other mentors
you will find information in the website
we have years of expertise in
computational biology bioinformatics and
also including emerging domains like
spaceomics so this network of mentors
that we have will provide you with
expert feedback and peer review from the
inception of your topic to the final
results and these results will be worthy
to be sharing among the scientific
community and to the world
and and one final challenge is
limited access to infrastructure that is
required to perform big data analysis
this is i think this is the most
important challenge that
many students face right now
so uh
the cloud-based analytical turbo
bioinformatics platform that you are
introduced to today it provides all the
infrastructures that is necessary to
perform big data analysis in an
intuitive environment with the help of
flexible interactive and visual
pipelines so the research fellows will
get access to this platform and a list
of curated public data sets with which
you can design a big data analytics
pipeline on multi-mix data or one can
perform translation research or one can
address clinical questions or biomarker
identification or treatment
certification or variety of question
that you can think about leveraging this
data and infrastructure
so who can benefit from such a research
fellowship program
so
this research fellowship program has
been designed to help young research and
students like you to gain access to the
premium resources on bioinformatics for
the analysis of complex high throughput
datasets that i presented before and uh
like dr harpith also presented and also
we
observed from oja also
so
and the experts will help you complete a
research study on your own so if you are
an undergraduate or a master's student
you can actually engage in research and
you can develop a deeper understanding
of the subject matter than that is
possible through uh through your
classroom routines or classroom
instructions alone so such an early
exposure to research has been proven to
be very helpful and can
can be the perfect launch pad for your
carrier you can also apply the skills
that is that is that is one of the most
important point you can apply all the
skills practically the skills that you
learnt from your classroom instructions
to a project of your own and to the
project of your
that piques your interest
and and more um
documentation wise you can fulfill the
requirements set by your university uh
said by your university syllabus or
curriculum so if you are a research
student so we provide uh you will get an
excellent opportunity to work one-on-one
with the network of mentors and to use
the tbio big data infrastructure to be
part of your research question or to be
an independent study to develop new
skills that they are interested in
interested to do that so with that uh i
thank you all for your
for your
interest and
attention and this concludes my
presentation and i think i would like to
pass the stage to subrajid barua he's an
astrobiologist and he works on space
omics and space health management
it's very exciting
to hear from you bridget please take
over the stage
well thank you so much dr raghav and it
was lovely hearing to you and your
perspective towards bioinformatics it's
used that it was amazing to learn about
that
any
sure
so it was amazing to learn and i hope
that our audience also has enjoyed every
bit of it and i hope that everybody's as
excited as i am
for
this particular research opportunity
which we call the research fellowship
now quickly i would just
talk about
a student club which is called cyomics
and
what is the agenda of this
club what are we targeting to do and
what would you benefit by being a part
of it well
hello everyone and thanks for tuning in
to today's webinar it was amazing to see
you all here meet you virtually and also
learn about such amazing opportunities
and research going around
and i'm sure that you are also kind of
interested or already starting to hope
that what can you do and how can you
contribute and how can you also be a
part of this exciting community well
that's something that i am going to talk
about today so my name is subrachit
bharwa and i am the scientific outreach
coordinator at find biotech and i am
also the president of the psionics
student club
i have an ms in molecular biology and
biotechnology from university saint
petersburg russia and i am a researcher
at the international laboratory of
solutions chemistry and applied
technologies
well to begin with psionics have been
making an impact all throughout the
globe since its inception
we have
a huge community of more than 1 000
enthusiasts all over the world we have
been
exposed to more than 20 great scientists
and their webinars all throughout we
also have a very strong alumni network
that consists of more than 30 successful
candidates from all over the world who
have been a part of a mixed logic
research fellowship or
fine biotech's research internships and
now they are out in the world making an
impact making a difference all
throughout the globe
so
let me talk a little bit about
what cyomics is all about and to do that
i would begin with a very simple story
of every student because you know i have
been a student i am a student
even now so i pretty well recognize
every student going through something of
this sort well
i know that you guys would also agree
and if you can
agree to that do let me know in the chat
section that
we do get interested in doing a research
very often right we get some idea we get
to know about some information we watch
some webinars some presentations and we
are so hyped up to begin our own
research journey maybe we have a task to
do we have a an internship to do or a
project to submit as a part of our
college curriculum so
we do get interested in doing a research
but there are certain barriers because
of which we are unable to complete it or
even if we complete it then we are not
very satisfied with whatever we get and
we just hope that there would have been
something better that we could have done
so what are these barriers well
sometimes we are unable to define a
proper research question which is of
relevance and which would be appreciated
by the scientific community because the
scientific community is so dynamic it
keeps on changing every day so maybe we
are not able to define the question as
required
sometimes we face one of the major
hurdles while doing any research project
is we can't find a good data set just
like dr raghava and also elia earlier
was talking about that finding a good
data set which is curated and which is
worthy of analysis bioinformatically
using the various tools and algorithms
statistically is a major challenge and a
very difficult task
finally
there can also arise a lack of skill
sets which are required in this modern
world
well we might know a lot of skills we
might have experience in many things but
you know
the world changes so fast so maybe we
need to develop and increase the level
of expertise that we have in the current
technologies out there in the world
but
why a student can't address these issues
well there can be various reasons some
of the possible reasons might be there's
no one to guide this particular student
they don't find someone enough close to
them who they can express their problem
their situation and who can be
like a mentor to them
then maybe they have some supervisors in
their college or their laboratories but
they're too scared or shy to talk to
them and consult them and maybe they
often think that the question that they
have or the doubt that they are bearing
in their mind is too silly to ask
someone
they might not know the places where you
can find good quality data for your
analysis out there which are publicly
available for anyone to analyze but we
don't really have the knowledge of where
to look for the data
finally there can be a major issue of
lack of motivation we might have that
enthusiasm to begin with a project but
maybe in the long run we just lose it
and we just pile it up somewhere up
there in a trunk
well
these are the
reasons or the issues which psionics
like to address at psionics we have a
huge community of experts and students
from all over the world with various
levels of experience and backgrounds
whom you can think of as your friend
philosopher guide whom you can talk to
there's no need to be shy because if you
join our community every day you will
find someone posting some questions
which might be uh not very big in a
matter of issue but it's definitely
treated with respect by every member of
the cyanics club because
we have been there we all have been
there we have all started from level
zero so
it's like that particular friend whom
you have always been
hoping for to arrive in your life with
whom you can talk with whom you can
discuss get advice and move on with your
research life also at find biotech just
as we heard from all the experts today
we have great
scientists with
loads of experience in academia and
industry who are there to guide you and
who can be your mentors for
making your research project actually
take shape and finally when you work in
a group when you see others progressing
you also develop that motivation to get
to the table to
power on your laptop and to get started
with your project to be at par with
everyone in that particular community so
that healthy competition atmosphere
motivates each one of us to make get the
best out of ourselves
so
here at psionics we would like to help
you
first of all to get a very good research
idea or a research question which is at
par with what's happening all around the
world right now
which you can get by attending several
guest lectures which would be absolutely
free of cost and they would be twice
every month so you get to attend their
lectures listen to them get their
advices learn about various
opportunities about research going on
around the world what's the cutting edge
situation right now in one particular
domain what's the skill sets required to
start your own research project then you
would get great mentors at find biotech
who can help you out with refining your
question with refining your idea and
also helping you out with the various
skills or the tools that you may need to
perform this particular research the
methods
finally you can
obviously talk to other peers who are
part of this club discuss problems
clarify your doubts talk about certain
errors that you might be coming across
in your particular
research project or talk about new
challenges which you can solve together
so that's a place where it happens where
you get new ideas and finally you would
also get access to various training
programs which would be launched by find
biotech in the near future which you can
get enrolled in to develop new skill
sets that are very much prominent in
today's world
so briefly i would like to talk about
what are the various areas of interests
to us the club members as well as to our
mentors well for example the buzzword
cancer we are interested in learning how
bioinformatics is changing the way we
treat cancer the way cancer research is
progressing and bioinformatics is at the
core of those sort of research so that
is definitely our number one interest we
are also very much interested in looking
at various metabolic diseases like
diabetes and also
we are interested in
knowing and learning the role of
bioinformatics in treating infectious
diseases like cova19 and ultimately
vaccine development because as you might
know the
rapid development of vaccines all around
the world was
facilitated
with the help of bioinformatics
especially and there's lots more that's
going on and that interests us many of
them are very new to this domain of
bioinformatics and omics for example
personalized medicine although not so
new but it's something which we are
beginning to get a grasp of at a very
young
level of our career so that's really
another exciting domain which we would
love to learn more from the guests and
from the experts and the mentors that we
have
chemi informatics that is the use of
bioinformatics to develop drug targets
and drug candidates with the help of
molecular docking and other tools that's
also something which are really
interests us
then comes my favorite area of
research which is astrobiology which
specifically is looking for molecular
signatures or biological signatures
throughout the universe not only limited
by the conditions on earth but also
beyond and not only that but also to
analyze the effects of space flight the
hazardous environment on the molecule
level of the astronauts and to actually
leverage bioinformatics to understand
what's going on in their bodies in the
cells and to use that knowledge
to transform the healthcare system on
earth itself there are numerous examples
of how that is being done but we will
talk about that maybe on one of the
psionics club sessions so
definitely do consider joining the club
then there's agrobiotic and much much
more that's going on
but the most exciting part which you
would get exposed to by being a part of
psionics club and also by being in close
contact with fine biotic is something
which is known as faculty-led projects
so pine biotech has a lot of
collaborations going on with
universities and other organizations all
around the world and every university or
organization have a big number of
faculties who are interested in one
particular domain of their research they
have been working on that domain for
years they have done their phds their
post docs and many years of research in
those particular areas now what you get
as a benefit by being a part of this
community is sometimes it might so
happen that you do not have a research
idea or a question of your own yet
because you are starting out right now
you are in the first or the second year
or the third year of your undergrad and
you are really getting exposed to
bioinformatics for the first time that's
pretty normal i have been at that place
myself even
so what's the best
way to get started at that particular
level is to get or to join a team of
some great faculty all around the world
who are working on their projects and
you just get to stand with them and look
at their projects look at the methods
that they're using look at how they are
addressing the various challenges how
they're shaping their question and you
get to learn a lot by doing that now
as you might understand it's often not
possible to
contact those faculties to go to their
organization to go to their places the
only time you can do that is when you go
for a research internship or something
like that and that's also for a short
period of time like three months but the
major advantage that you get by being a
part of cyanocomics and also by staying
in close contact with find biotech is
you get exposed to such faculty-led
project opportunities all throughout the
world not only in your country but also
beyond now you can participate in their
research teams get to work closely with
them attend
team meetings get to know the ways and
the strategies they are developing to
address the challenges and the way they
are formulating their research project
and i find this particular opportunity
really exciting because it can transform
your entire career of bioinformatics
research in the future
so how would specifically our mentors
and the courses which elias showed you
in the beginning of the webinar that are
already listed in the portal help you
with your research project and
to really get started with your research
journey well they would help you to
put together all the pieces of the
puzzle to do our research is a big
puzzle because there are various pieces
like literature review finding a
good data set finding or defining a good
research question then
bringing together all the required
methods interpreting the results and
coming up with the conclusion these are
all pieces of a puzzle
but if they can be put together in a
logical way they would look a beautiful
picture like we see in a jigsaw puzzle
so
that expertise that guidance to do that
will be provided by our mentors and all
the asynchronous courses that you can go
through yourself and also give you a
direction in which you can head
in the future
how where you could get a master degree
or a phd or maybe a job opportunity in
the future all of this guidance and
these information would be provided by
our mentors and you would get that if
you are a part of the psionics students
club
now this model of whatever i said has
been tested and proven by various
students but today i would like to share
my experience or my journey in brief
that how i benefited personally from
this sort of model so how i started
learning bioinformatics as a young
student who's doing his undergrad and
knows nothing about bioinformatics heard
the term for the first time literally
and ending up becoming a space omix
researcher which is completely a niche
domain which is practically very new and
very few people are working in this
particular domain
so
as you might have guessed i was also a
research intern at find biotech that's
where i got baptized in bioinformatics
got to know about the various tools got
to know about what is data science in
biology
how accumulated data set looks like how
we can use the various pipelines the
various tools interpret the results
formulate a research question
give shape to a research project
everything i learned here so you can see
that was my certificate of the
internship that i did and here are some
other certificates that i earned by
going through the various tutorials out
there in the pioneer tech portal so this
is a place where i
got all the necessary information to
begin with
and then
one fine day i was looking through
television and various other blogs so as
you might have already known you guys
have also come across various shows and
such
materials in discovery or any other
channels that astronauts face a lot of
problems when they
embark on a space mission when they go
to space and that's all because of
microgravity radiation isolation etc
like bone and muscle density loss
physical strain cancer gut microbiome
changes etc etc but that's not where i
stopped i took one step further to
translate this information or this need
for
looking into this particular domain to
convert it into my research interest and
convert it into my research project so
that's where again i got connected with
pine biotic i approached them with my
idea and they were very happy to welcome
this idea although it was new and a very
niche domain they helped me all
throughout the journey the excellent
mentors at find biotech helped me at
every stage helped me address every
challenge that i faced and finally i
could devise some result out of the
research question that i had which gets
aligned to nasa's human research program
that is basically to identify and to
address the challenges faced by human
beings on inside the space conditions so
as you might see some of those research
are already in the pre-print condition
right now and they are i'm hoping that
they will get published but that's not
where i stop because this is just the
beginning now i am looking towards other
data sets more complex datasets more
complex organisms to look into and more
complex pathways and biological
processes which are out there to be
analyzed these data sets are available
in the public domain
what they require is the proper interest
the proper motivation and the proper
guidance to analyze and get something
very meaningful and helpful
like useful from those particular data
sets and that's how being a part of this
rich community helps you that's how much
the bigger part of the community can
elevate your ideologies and your
experiences
and as you might
have already guessed this is where
everybody of us once have been the stage
where we get an idea
and this is where we want to be we want
to be successful we want to make an
impact we want to announce ourselves
into this domain that yeah we have also
done something but there's a big gap
between that those two areas and that's
the gap which psionics loves to bridge
and that's our vision to provide you
with the necessary amount of guidance
the necessary amount of resources
information and tools to go from here to
here and
make an impact into the world
so
in a nutshell the agenda of psionics
looks like this we would help you to
learn about the current research
standards and challenges present out
there in various domains of interests
all throughout we would also help you
and provide access to various new skills
and also our mentors would help you
define impactful research questions and
finally
our community would also help you to
interpret results published in various
journals or presented in some great
conferences all throughout
how do we aim to provide you the
information well as i said by inviting
guests who have lots of experience from
all over the world
in various domains for a webinar which
you can attend for free and here's what
the timeline which is quite tentative
but still is in our action of plan
uh so in november we have the theme of
cancer so we will be having two great
speakers talk about cancer their
research opportunities in december we
would have infectious diseases in
january we will talk about astrobiology
in february metagenomics microbiome
and march personalized medicine and so
on and so forth it will go on and on
without stop and every month there would
be a new theme a new particular domain
of science and bioinformatics which
would be addressed talked about and all
of you are welcome to be a part of it so
if
all of this sounds exciting and good to
you do consider joining cya mix today
it's absolutely free of cost we do not
charge anything to be a part of psionics
and to get access to the community as
well as the various guest lectures so
you can join us through whatsapp so
through telegram or slash channels the
details will be shared you can also find
all those details on social media
platforms of find biotech or my social
media platform so if you want to stay in
touch with me get in touch with me via
linkedin or instagram or twitter and i
would love to talk to you and if you
guys have any questions feel free to put
them in the chat i would love to address
them and finally hope to see you in the
next ionic sessions good luck with your
research journey and i wish all of you
all the best
so
right now i would
pass it on to sonalika to take the
session further thank you so much for
listening to me today
thank you so much subrashi for sharing
with us about the psionics class i'm
sure the club is doing some amazing work
and i have also shared the link of the
slack group with you all so this is what
the stack group looks like and if you
have registered yourself on the program
page then you are going to get the
invitation to be a part of the slack
channel automatically so all you need to
do just click on the link and you will
be redirected to the slack channel also
we have a sky and group of the details
of which has already been shared in the
chat box
so now uh
we i'll be just taking you all uh with
the registration process and also many
of you asked about these scholarships so
let's now discuss how you proceed for to
enroll yourself for this very exciting
research fellowship program and get
started with your research project
so uh
once you visit this research fellowship
program page you are going to get all
the details that you are supposed to
know uh for the program and today we
discussed these three steps in greater
detail that is you are going to get
ready through training and then find an
impactful research topic and present
your analysis for expert feedback the
three major outcomes of the research
fellowship
program could be either you could come
up with a literature review or present
your research work uh
in a poster presentation competition
maybe and the third one is definitely is
definitely publishing your research work
in repetitive journals
and here on the program page itself you
will get the details of all the mentors
you heard from some of the mentors today
and also you could register yourself in
the form here which is mentioned in the
program page
and once you register yourself you are
going to get all the details about how
you can further enroll yourself for the
program and how to get started
now we do understand the need to make
this program reasonable for students
along with the basic requirement of
sustaining the program all together so
we have designed this new program page
for the computational biology internship
program or the fellowship program so
don't get confused between these two
terms at many places for the term
internship fellowship code is being used
so uh you could find the basic structure
of the research fellowship program here
on the page itself how do we proceed
further so first of all you all would be
supposed to go through a course material
and then come up with your research
proposal submit your research question
and then get started with your research
project and how do we meet we are going
to meet uh twice every week to take up
your doubts and uh
see your progress and also suggest you i
recommend you the further steps that
should be followed to carry out your
project
and
you can go through the structure here on
the program page which is very well
defined
and to join the uh research fellowship
program you can take up the license here
on the page itself so we have three
licenses the first one is beginners the
second one is intermediate and the third
one is advanced
now these three levels are based on the
different types of features
it includes
so uh the beginner level does not
include the one-on-one mentorship that
is that you could take up your doubts in
group sessions and also many times
participants are not able to take up
their doubts in a group session
maybe because they're not able to
clarify their doubts clearly or they do
require a one-on-one meeting with the
mentor so that could be taken up in the
intermediate license and then for the
advanced license we also have the
technical support that is being provided
along with one-on-one mentorship and
also we have different types of license
on the t bio info platform that elias
showed you uh all so there is a
specialization license an educational
license and a research license now this
license has a different uh provisions
that it's going to provide you to work
with your data in the educational
license you would be able to use the
big data from the various big data
repositories upload the data and work on
it and in a research license if you are
generating your own data or you are from
a lab or a phd student maybe then you
can upload your own data using an ftp
account and carry out the analysis
so this is the page where you can uh
just enroll yourself using
like taking up any of the license that
you would like to uh take up and enroll
and
uh
then
on this page itself you will also get to
know about the various courses and
sample projects that you can go through
now all the courses that uh india also
showed you as a part of the research
fellowship program all the courses and
the example projects would be unlocked
for you all so everything here uh under
the courses uh tab
you can go through and learn from
now there is one more aspect that i
would like to share with you all that is
the scholarship application
so we do have a monthly module of
license that you all can take up and be
a part of the program so the module that
i just showed you that is a monthly
module that is you have to take up this
monthly license and carry out your
research work but if you would like to
take up the license uh for a three
months research fellowship program or a
six months program altogether then you
are eligible to take up or apply for a
scholarship application as well and this
is the scholarship
application form
that i will be just sharing in the chat
box
once you uh fill this scholarship form
we we will review your application and
get back to you um to tell you how much
scholarship you're going to get for the
research fellowship program and that's
the way you can get yourself enrolled
now i would like to leave the stage open
for everyone to take the doubts please
put in the doubts in the chat section or
you can also raise your hand and unmute
yourself to take up your doubt
i just wanted to clarify on a few things
that we have just mentioned and hello
everyone myself mohit mazumdar i'm one
of the commenters and uh
[Music]
and representatives who are working on
collaborations
today i wanted to discuss few things
with all of you so we have some some of
the exciting collaborations that we
recently did signing some of the mmu's
with some of
the university
departments who are involved in research
some of the departments who are involved
in training and also
industry where
we have people from different pharma
industry and the biotechnology industry
to help students guide
through
so
about the licensing um which sonata was
mentioning it's actually a subscription
so
when you're taking a monthly
subscription you're paying monthly these
can be done for in two months three
months and six months the structure
works for
different models so if you are thinking
about taking a two-month uh
research program you can go for uh
either a beginner subscription or a
intermediate subscription or an advanced
subscription so obviously these are
different subscription levels that are
available for you to take by monthly if
you choose to you know take the
mentorship and take all the resources or
the premium resources and develop a
project but obviously you can start from
a very beginner's level that would not
require you to take any license uh not
require you to pay anything
just uh
join uh the omixlogic uh portal
and then you can also take help from
cyanic uh cyanics group as mentioned by
subraject that would help you develop
such research question and then you can
take the decision to go for big data
analysis so one of the reasons that
there is a substitution to this program
is because that we are um
actually providing you with a platform
to do big data analysis and that
platform itself would require us to you
know uh show give you a lot of space on
cloud as well as access to all the
resources that we have developed so
that's why there is a subscription and
coming back to the
question
uh that crystal has uh that she's saying
i'm brazilian and have no money
uh so that's perfectly fine we have
different types of scholarships that are
available for
different kind of responsibilities so
crystal we also have a research
campus ambassador program
which you can join and one of the basic
objectives of that program is that you
bring awareness about bioinformatics
about omics logic training in your area
and
we kind of get that in a form of a
report and then we provide you a full
scholarship to do this program
for three months or six months so that
is also a way to do this for a program
and get supported but that would require
you to give a lot of time uh and effort
and learning and applying all of this so
the best way to develop a project is
obviously
to work directly with the mentor uh
do the research webinars
i mean come and join the research
webinars weekly uh and discuss your
problems so we are available 24 7 and
then there are like online
courses and the portal that you just saw
which is available 24 7. so all of this
actually combines to become a omixlogic
program or a research fellowship program
and um i just wanted to quickly share
with you about some of the um
some of the
university programs that we have so we
have collaborated with uh amity
university
in jaipur and in noida and if you are a
student there you can reach out to us
and you can let us know and we will be
able to help you
with uh registration relevant to the
university so um just to tell you about
the three different collaborations and
the collaboration with industry so we
recently um
just a second
so uh we recently collaborated uh with
amity university jaipur and there's a
reason somehow i'm not been able to
share the full screen
and we discussed about different
multi-omics
courses and integration of you know
uh integration of our
programs into their
internships so students will be joining
from amity university jaipur today when
over 130 people joined and we discussed
about the entire
research fellowship program and
development of projects in group so one
of the way to make it sustainable is to
also work on group project or
collaborative project and all of the
things that we have discussed today and
all of the things that we've been able
to achieve is because of the
collaborations it's because of that that
we're working as a team so one of the
biggest aspect of this kind of you know
um
training and this kind of community is
about collaboration is about
understanding each other is about you
know doing uh these uh tasks uh by
dividing the tasks and by
showcasing
our own expertise in different areas
so similarly uh we have a collaboration
uh done with cgc landrum chandigarh
and then we have launched the research
fellowship program for the students
there and they'll be there also we are
working with
department of biotechnology microbiology
and
pharmacy to help students develop
research projects in those areas and
work through these different uh
resources and that all starts from the
basic training that all starts from like
going through those basics that has been
reiterated over and over and then uh we
do have
another collaboration with amity
university uh noida which turned out to
be like a
historic kind of a collaboration because
it involved uh several departments so we
are talking about at least six to eight
departments within amity university
uttar pradesh and then defining of those
research questions during that
several you know
meetings that we had so we had
brainstorming sessions where we
discussed that how this can be
integrated how the expertise from you
know faculty can be integrated into a
program where we can help students
giving them a holistic understanding of
how to work on or define a research
project and then work with the
faculty-led research project as
shivrajeet was telling in his
presentation so these are some of the
opportunities that are there with
universities and those universities who
have reached out to us and obviously we
are working on different type of
projects within those universities along
with that one major collaboration that i
would wanted to you know
showcase to you all
is is uh the collaboration with industry
which is with faba academy which we
recently did and in this meeting we
discussed about uh how we can help how
industry can help in recruitment how
industry can help in giving job
opportunities and we met with
people here as you can see on the screen
that are
leaders in industry leaders in
biotechnology they are represented in
big pharma
companies and they are also working with
ai and drug discovery so one of the
objective of this collaboration is to be
able to develop resources in data
science and ai in healthcare and
i'll be working very closely with the
group of people here developing
technologies and resources for students
and also giving students an opportunity
to work on projects related to ai
in drug discovery where we are thinking
about you know small molecules molecule
screening uh in using information from
protein folding structure prediction
using alpha fold
that you must have heard about um
that was uh recently came out and
surprised the
um the structure of biology world and
not only the structural biology but
maybe the entire world so another
application data science and ai in
clinical trials so this is a huge also
when it comes to ai based drug discovery
so what we are trying to do and what we
are trying to do in this program
would be helping you decide on some of
the important research areas first and
then go to another step to work and
develop the research project so if you
are not sure like which research area
that you are you know uh more interested
about then you can go about the
intermediate training after doing the
basics that would tell you about these
different uh research areas such as
precision medicine population health
agriculture and biotechnology
spaceomics that we discuss in length so
uh you'll be able to work on 21st
century problems and
i'll be available to help you as a
mentor so i have expertise and over 40
publications in different research
addressing different research questions
using bioinformatics so please feel free
to reach out to me
and reach out to our team and we'll be
able to help you uh go through and
complete this journey and you already
saw the subscription levels for the
research fellowship program you know
about the psionics program and it will
be great if you also can become the
ambassador of these programs and help
others who can be a good fit for this so
with that i would like to conclude
today's session and it was really really
great to see you all and i really like
to thank um dr raghavendra and dr
harpreet ilya and shinalikan subrajeet
for giving us wonderful lectures
throughout this way and we will be
looking forward to meet you next week so
next week also we have a wonderful
session coming up and we'll be emailing
you about that uh on different homicide
programs that we just discussed so we'll
be talking about infectious diseases in
much more detail we will talk we'll talk
about metagenomics we'll talk about
genomics we will talk about
transcriptomics and these specialization
programs are how they are helpful in
developing and in understanding and
finding those research questions
thank you
thank you so much dr mohamed thank you
so much everyone for being a part of the
webinar and making it such a wonderful
event today and uh if you have not
registered yourself then do register so
that you get the links to all the groups
that you can join and stay updated about
the program thank you everyone we'll be
meeting soon bye